code miko has had a pretty rough couple
of weeks
last week the popular v tuber was
slapped with her fourth band after her
character model appeared on screen
completely naked and in the same 24
hours her house was the scene of an
alleged altercation between her and some
tick talkers we actually have a lot of
questions about this so let's dive in
and see what we can figure out
[Music]
so before i confuse the hell out of
anybody who doesn't know who code miko
is allow me to give you a short
explainer miko is a v tuber meaning she
typically streams as a virtual avatar
rather than her own self what makes her
more unique is that she ditches the
traditional anime characters for more
life-like 3d models on top of that young
kang the woman behind code miko is a 3d
artist and vr designer meaning she could
basically do or become anything she
wanted on stream anything i have someone
that you can meet okay
okay let's see it
oh no wait what is that
using her pretty sophisticated mocap
technology miko's been able to break out
as one of the most innovative creators
on twitch and the character miko has
become widely known for her interview
streams they become a staple on the
channel and are responsible for some
truly entertaining moments did anyone
tell you that you're kind of
intimidating all the time it's my
bulging muscularity and just absolutely
disgusting stature i'm i'm standing at a
beautiful five foot six like going
through doorways is oftentimes burning
some it's just massive shoulders popping
through are you only five foot six
did you say only
did i hear that
it's cute
but as entertaining as her streams can
be they can also be a bit chaotic and
often push the boundaries of what's
allowed on the platform as a result miko
gets banned a lot and for varying
reasons it's actually gotten to the
point where during an interview with dr
k which is resident psychiatrist they
discussed whether or not miko has
developed ptsd over the bands that you
know just the little parts that you
mentioned
you know do make me think that it's
warrant it's it warrants getting an
actual evaluation i've never heard of
something like this before
um
but
you know there are
treatments if you have real ptsd
unfortunately her stream on july 6
didn't really help her situation too
much ironically titled code miko might
get banned today miko told her chat they
would be doing a homeless simulator even
making her backdrop a graffiti-covered
back alley so already not the best start
but this is code miko we're talking
about so she pushed the envelope even
further with well let's call it a
wardrobe change let's do it okay let's
do the homeless simulator
but
you can't be homeless if you look like
this so
what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna fix up my wardrobe a little
bit okay i i
i think i need to be naked
someone
this is the most perfect homeless
simulator i've ever seen
we're ready everyone out oh god please
don't do that please do not abuse the
future homeless person okay
yes although fully blurred mika was
naked and for anyone who's interested
the rest of the stream carried out with
some puking and use of an unknown white
substance but despite the title of her
stream miko actually thought she was in
the clear she was obviously toeing the
line but technically never showed any
nudity but what miko thinks isn't really
important what matters is what twitch
tos says about it well if you're
interested i am glad because they have
an entire page dedicated to their policy
on nudity and sexual content so let's
try to look at this objectively twitch
has a lot of rules on this subject which
allows them to cast a large net when
banning people technically speaking
mikko could fall under a lot of these
exploitation and nudity rules she was
after all naked and role-playing as a
homeless person and even though code
miko is a digital character twitch says
that avatars fall under the same
stipulations for coverage and twitch
says coverage of areas that require it
must be fully opaque anything else would
be against tos it's possible that twitch
doesn't see pixelation as satisfactory
in fact they don't say anything in their
tos about pixelation or blurring for
that matter what interests me is if
black bars covering those areas would
suffice they technically are opaque
regardless of that twitch made their
decision and mika was hit with another
ban however the story doesn't end there
in the same 24 hours miko tweeted that
four tick talkers tried to get access to
her house without permission the group
who were strangers to everyone living
with mikko claimed that they used to
live there and wanted to come inside to
have a look and after being denied
access to the house and told to leave
the property several times the tick
tocker allegedly threw a rock at mikko's
roommate and fellow streamer just minx
even tearing through the screen door
yeah but he's wrong dude it's just
really talking it's just a house we
don't know you
no no you just came to our house we're
doing [ __ ] no wait let me let me tell
you you just came to a [ __ ] house
expecting blaine
why are you throwing what just oh
afterwards minks apparently spat at them
chased them down the street and
challenge them to a fight
so business is usual for minx luckily it
seems that no one was hurt during the
entire altercation since then there has
been a ton of unconfirmed reports of the
situation including a false accusation
and whether or not minx tossed a vase
off her balcony but since then miko's
side has said that they won't drop the
names of the tick tocker since this
might now be an investigation and if
things couldn't get worse for miko she
posted a photo of her at the hospital
with a massive lump on her head but keep
in mind this was not from the
altercation and she gave varying answers
to how this happened all in all it's a
pretty [ __ ] week if you ask me but this
is miko so she's had a pretty good
attitude about everything as far as her
ban goes it was only a day and she's
since been back doing irl streams but
that ban still raises a few questions
about twitch's tos policy and how
intentionally unclear it is if we look
back at miko's second ban it was for
soliciting pornography which of course
she wasn't actually doing no during that
stream if you sent mikko a dollar she
would get a photo of the letter d sent
to her phone that's it so what was
essentially just a silly joke was
equated to soliciting pornography and we
actually covered this situation when it
happened back when miko was skyrocketing
in popularity but also seemingly getting
banned constantly listen miko pushes the
boundaries of what's allowed no one's
denying that but if you were to scroll
through twitch right now i'm sure you'd
find a lot of things more against tos
than anything she's ever done and when
it comes to twitch and although it pains
me to say this they're allowed to have
these rules and if you were to look at
any other company's tos it'd probably be
equally as vague but at the same time
twitch relies on every single content
creator for them to survive so i don't
think it's a lot to ask for them to at
least clarify their tos that or at least
provide consistent banning sure getting
banned for a day after streaming your
avatar naked in a back alley is an
insane sentence to say but these bands
are actually important to a lot of
content creators
eventually a perma band can come your
way and potentially end your career
is that pop or cold it's cold bro
just have a nice a nice
diet dr pepper in the morning
i know it's wild i remember going on
hockey tournaments on the american teams
like being bright and early and just
drinking
diet pepsi